um just want to remind our viewers what
you said um the government said as part
of their manifesto pledge this um to
increase the defense budget each year by
0.5 percent above inflation will the
government be abiding by that pledge
well i think a number 10 spokesman said
yesterday that they thought that was
unlikely given the
significant changes to inflation uh as
defense secretary my most important
target is remaining above two percent if
not greater of gdp which is the main
nato benchmark
and you know i think that's really
important that we continue to commit to
that if not greater and i think that's
what we're all here to discuss today in
uh madrid
two percent enough
well we're currently above two percent
uh at the
for this spending period that's the four
years of spending settlement i got from
the treasury we are on target to meet
our two percent
and we're also
on target in other areas with our sort
of defense reforms the question is
really the next spending period the
middle of the decade
we were prepared to take certain
vulnerabilities
on board in the middle of the decade as
we got rid of some equipment and
re-equipped with new
i think the invasion of russia
you know into ukraine has changed that
and that's why i think the discussions
are so important for the sort of middle
of the decade funding so between now and
my convention spending review settlement
which ends in 2024 uh you know the here
and now we are rightly set we've got 24
billion pounds of record settlement the
question is what happens uh in the
middle of the decade and the future uh
if uh security and threat
becomes more of an issue is 2.14 enough
i'm a defense secretary of department
all departmental heads okay will say
they want more money
of course
in the here and now absolutely we have
enough money enough money for next year
as well you know but what you discover
in in government in in different
departments is despite getting the sums
you've got to then spend them properly
and i've been determined to make sure we
are spending our money and getting it
out the door i think i think what you'll
see
across the whole range of government
departments is that despite settlements
it's often quite hard to you can't
immediately start building a hospital or
immediately start uh building roads and
that's no different for defense so look
for the here and now and for that
comprehensive spending review settlement
we are absolutely in the right place
post 2024 is really the discussions i
have with the chancellor and the prime
minister uh that i you know i i feel and
i said in a speech yesterday that you
know the security of this country is
vital that the work the men and women of
our armed forces do is incredibly
important we've all fasted in their
success in helping with kovid with
afghanistan not pitting and now leading
from the front on ukraine and i think
that means that britain wants to
maintain his leadership role post 2024
we're going to have to see probably
greater investment we've we've spent 40
years nearly taking a peace dividend out
of the end of the cold war sometimes
it's important to invest the prime
minister changed that direction of
travel which was excellent news back in
2020 when he did the settlement gave me
the record funding that was a change of
what had happened for decades previously
where people took money out of defense
every time
so we need to continue that that
direction of investment and if we do i
think we'll be able to give an armed
forces that continues to help us lead
around the world okay you're telling my
viewers that for now we're in the right
place yesterday you said for too long
defense has lived on a diet of smoke and
mirrors hollowed out formations and
fantasy efficiency savings
yeah and that's why the prime minister
changed that direction with my
settlement 2020. uh the 24 billion
pounds
a net increase in defense spending the
biggest since the cold war was exactly
to to answer that point so
it actually says that in the full speech
okay if you read further into the speech
you'll see me say that you know that's
why the prime minister reversed decades
of direction of travel on defence the
key for me is defence secretary is to
make sure
that that you know government's appetite
for using its defense forces is matched
uh by its resources puts in place i i
can deliver an armed forces to keep
britain safe i can deliver an armed
forces to
be able to support our allies in the
world and stand up for our values but
but that will that obviously has to be
cut to our cloth and i think that's
really important that we always make
sure we do it the part in history prime
ministers around you know have often
volunteered defense to do all sorts of
things and never then funded it this
prime minister has done that but i'm
just really keen that we recognize that
my settlement was done before russia
invaded ukraine russia is very very
dangerous and now on the world stage the
world is less secure than it was two
three years ago and is not looking
likely to change for the rest of the
decade i think that's the moment in the
middle of the decade to say we should
commit to increased funding okay um i
read in my weekend papers that you wrote
the prime minister asking for a 20 hike
in military spending was that the case
no
how much would you like
well how long's piece of string look i i
i could i can see opportunities all over
the world okay to to put the front foot
forward of the british forces again that
goes back to my earlier point about the
appetite of the government and how much
it wants to do
uh i i of course i want always enough to
meet the threat you know my my duty
uh to to you to the citizens of the uk
and and indeed to the country and our
allies is to have a
provide the government with a defense
force capable enough to defend against
the threats if the threat changes then
we should always consider uh that type
of investment to match it we do that in
many other departments around government
you know when when the nhs comes under
winter pressures for decades and decades
you know chancellors of the day have
stepped up and invested to meet that
response obviously
winter pressures in the army are
slightly different they they take place
over you know five six years but
nevertheless if the threat changes we
should always be open to increasing that
funding i've said that a number of
occasions before that's the right way to
do it because i'm i'm a threat-led
organization
and for now between now and 2084 we are
in the right place the question comes
next what happens next okay um as
defense secretary um are you completely
content that as a country we spend
apparently proportionately less than
greece lithuania and estonia
well i think
look we are actually the second biggest
spender at the moment in europe we are
also i think the third biggest spender
in the world in defence so we spend a
lot of money if you talk about in cash
terms on defense obviously britain's gdp
or britain's cut britain's economy is
far bigger than some of those countries
you've just listed and therefore uh if
you spend even a baseline of of defence
that comes close to one percent or two
percent uh that would be comparable to
us you'll discover that you know some of
those countries that higher percentage
reflects the fact their gdp their
economy is much smaller but overall
that we we have been the leader i'm
determined that we stay the leader in
the pack of that defence spend and
that's why i'm keen that we address the
sort of post-country d4 period
what's the point of um having a
manifesto pledge like uh 0.5 above
inflation spending on the defense budget
or saying that 300 000 new homes per
year are going to be built by the
mid-2020s or saying that 0.70 of gdp
will be spent on foreign aid or or that
we're going to get full fiber broadband
around the country by 2025 points of a
manifesto if you don't keep your
promises
well i
first of all i've been in politics long
enough kate you've seen every government
not fulfill 100 it's manifesto i i mean
what's the point then
what's the point of a manifesto if
you're not going to keep your point
with an offer to the public okay it's
saying what we are going to try and
deliver and deliver as a government it
it is you can call it a promise we we we
promise to try and do these things but
some things it's more of a wish list
than a promise
right okay
do i think the manifesto we have today
would look the same
if it had been written
post covered or during covert i think it
would have been different and i think
covered was a once in a hundred year
once in a pla 100 year plus type issue
and also we have an economic issue you
know
that that means we have to i mean a
responsible government would take
difficult decisions in light of the
facts changing i've just been saying to
uk about threat if threat changes we
should we should change our investments
in defence with it it is a perfectly
legitimate position to be in
and i think if the economic situation
has changed or all things are harder to
deliver than people thought and remember
to be fair
it's not always as straightforward there
are always other factors that affect us
these things sometimes take longer than
we would have liked but but you know it
doesn't mean to say it's not an
aspiration you know under this
government the prime minister did change
absolutely changed the uh
defence investment he did something that
hadn't been done for decades and you
know if inflation hadn't
lifted off uh basically this year we
would be on track to meet our 0.5
percent
uh talk to me uh quickly um about
something that's also quite close to
your heart and that's scotland of course
we're hearing from nicola sturgeon she
said i've had enough of the uk
government and we're going to have a
referendum one way or another on
independence what would you say in
response to them
i went into the scottish politics
scottish parliament with nicola sturgeon
literal servants had enough of
westminster since 1999 when i went into
the scottish parliament with her the
problem is she's had enough of that but
she hasn't actually done her job of
delivering for the people of scotland
better healthcare better schools better
crime rates better uh education and all
the things that are really important
people scotland and instead she's uh
desperate i think now to have a have a
second referendum even though
all the promises were
a referendum is a once in a generation
well
there was a a referendum it was all
pretty much handed over to the scottish
parliament to decide on everything from
its wording to its timing they had they
had the referendum uh they lost the
referendum uh and instead of them saying
okay hands up let's try and see if
there's a better way let's try and
better the people
of scotland's experience with public
services she's just banged on on the
same one-trick pony i think the problem
for nichola is time is running out
and you know i think she knows because
for all the sort of spin she put on
separation she knows that every day that
goes past every day further away from
her sort of referendum zeal or the
division that she stoked up the first
time round uh people are feeling that
belonging to the united kingdom is
probably a better option and the reason
they want to belong to the united
kingdom is if you look at covid the
scale of support scotland could only
have been delivered by a greater
political union if you look at defense
you've got president putin in nuclear on
numerous occasions
and you know people in scotland realize
that we are greater together better
together as a nation okay you've
definitely had your three shredded week
this morning i can't get word in
edgeways just one final question before
i let you go pressure on the pm harriet
harman chair of the privileges committee
new chair of the privileges committee um
that will be looking into uh party gate
and the prime minister any concerns
about her appointment
no it's a matter for parliament uh you
know i i leave it to
the parliamentary uh arithmetic the the
the people on the panel uh you know
those committees are deliberately set up
so that we have an opposition member
chairing that panel that's that's how
governments and standards should be held
to account we often do that on a range
of of different select committees but i
think the reality is
she yes of course she's the chair i'm
sure all the mps on there will look at
the facts and take their own decision